good morning and welcome to this
licensing subcommittee meeting on
wednesday the 28th september 2021 we are
sitting today under the licensing act
2003 to hear an application made under
the act
my name is councillor jeanette stiltz
and i have been appointed the chair for
this meeting
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members the setup for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for kobe
therefore can i ask or present to work
to the protocols agreed council on the
2nd of september 2021
in the interest of member and office of
safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up indicate you
wish to speak and then i will invite you
to
at the appropriate time
when invited to speak remember to turn
your microphone off on and turn it off
when finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda
papers like the agenda papers and keep
your contributions as clear and concise
as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind the top table
apologies for absence
bernar have we got any apologies for
absence
chairman no we've received none thank
you
item for disclosure of interest to
disclose the existence of a nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusives of the code of conduct
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
neither advise throughout the meeting
do i have any
interests
thank you
item five on the agenda is the exclusion
of the press and public
i moved the
chairman to move that the committee
results are under sections 100 a
4 of the local government act 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting for
the following items of business on the
agenda under the grounds that they
involve the likely disclosure
of exempt information as defined in
paragraph one of part one of schedule
12a to the act
and that this
satisfies the public interest test do i
have a second aspect yes thank you
do members wish to agree that by ascent
i agreed
thank you
we're off
you